hey what's up guys welcome to you
winners on a Wednesday every single week
I bring people onto the show that have
become successful financially free
killing it in property as a result of
the training that we provide and this
week I'd like to introduce to you Zack
and Dan awesome to have you guys on the
show thanks for coming up yeah thanks
for having us so you guys came to the
crash course a few months back yeah in
June 21st
ok so super super Eastern you now done
something doing some crazy deals what's
happened so beginning of August
we've got approached by a company that
needed property a five dollar property
source for him and they had a hundred
ninety million to play with and they
offered at one hundred and ninety
million
so you didn't 10x it you 100x next there
because the numbers are the same just
with extra zeros yeah exactly yeah so
they needed properties in there in the
north kind of area and we were offered
one percent of the acquisition price of
the property per property via source for
them so that's potentially 1.9 million
in in profit for us if we saw the 1918
that's insane so let's get a little bit
the back story because to have people
like that approach you and say they want
to do business with you is obviously
huge is mega what did you learn that was
so valuable that you've got companies
like this with that kind of money saying
that they want to work with teenagers
like talk to me through how that works
so what's your background do you have
like a business background or what so we
both initially have sort of a business
background because we started businesses
from the age of 11 yeah mainly in the
marketing field so influence marketing
really for me
organizing Bradley brandy or stuff like
that paper motion yeah main paid
promotion we get commissioned from these
influences and then prop she has always
been a passion for us but we always grew
up to believe that you have to save a
lot money get mortgage and let it out
there's no other way to make money in
property
apparently so then I first discovered
you was on the BBC program this week the
landlord moved in yeah and then I was
just started watching YouTube content
yeah
and then I was like two down one day we
offer you have to get into this and then
we booked ourselves on the caucus I
think there's a lot of people that I
mean I get I get quite a lot of
teenagers watch me on YouTube and it's
great having you guys on the show
because the fact that you say you
started the first business at 11:00 and
you've been working with youtubers and
influencers the the way that you think
most people that are teenagers they
almost talk themselves out of starting
yet because I think oh I'll understand
ager therefore I'm not further you guys
are big thinkers big players teenagers I
was a teenager when I started it's it's
great to get an understanding of how you
think and what the difference is between
you guys and the 18 19 year old guys
watching this like how can they also do
big things have you know so what what
gives you that kind of confidence to be
able to think I can work with youtubers
I'm a marketer I'm gonna start my own
business up I'm gonna get into property
to think that way where does that
confidence come from it's important to
know what you're talking about so gain
educated really is one big thing you
know which I think mania we're confident
comes in so yeah we did a lot of
research we spoke to a lot of people in
the industry yeah a lot of trial and
error even if we weren't a hundred
percent or something we still went for
it and if you don't work out it's a
lesson learned from it well how do
people I mean starting business so young
and I know now you're not that young but
you're still young but how do you get
around the fear of thinking they won't
take me seriously I don't know what I'm
talking about do people take you
seriously or did they when you started
it was it was a bit of 50-50 some people
did they love what we do from sea
Plastics pass work but some people here
they didn't they don't want to work with
us at all it's just the way you present
yourself really and how you come across
someone but you guys come here in suit
looking great short sharp hair you know
and I think that that's really important
so why don't you learn at the crash
course then and what happened on the
bond the property front you confident
businesspeople you've got a background
in working with influencers and
youtubers you want to get into property
you come to the crash course just a
couple few months back what happened and
once you know how to find the deals yeah
you have a good enough product then
people are going to come to you okay
yeah yeah that's so important what about
self yes same exactly what Dan said
we've taken on a lot of information we
network with so many people I think that
was the one big benefit as well speaking
to other like-minded individuals
technically I'm telling you one of the
things I find really interesting about
your story and also about business in
general I find that the marketplace is
not a just or racist or discriminative
like the marketplace all it cares about
is can you bring the value so if you're
12 years old but you're able to find
good deals then you're gonna get paid
well exactly if the figures stack up
that's all that'll really investigate I
don't care where it comes from it's just
if the return of investment is there it
would be stupid not to go free they look
at the deal did you get did you get your
guys did they sound like a nondisclosure
agreement yeah I expect so you cuz
because you know you know what happens
these big players these big investors
they'll take advantage of people you
know so so okay so you came to the crash
course you had your eyes opened you
learned about how to find good deals so
talk to us about that and how do you
find how do you find deals that attract
the likes of multi multi millionaires
well for us it is quite handy they
basically approached us and just gave us
a mandate so they said this is a
criteria go in five properties so it's
quite easy for us to then start ringing
agents in the areas that they were
looking yeah I think Aiden for your best
friend in this industry if you create a
good relationship for them you just have
properties is flowing to you even
off-market property oh yeah of course
but again like most people watching this
they're teenagers they'll be too scared
to go speak to agents what what does the
conversation look like them with an
agent so you don't know the area you
don't know any agents but you wanna get
in with them what do you do what do you
say
so we first start by doing a bit of due
diligence on the market around the area
with them and we ask a few basic
questions in-house the area what kind of
tenants are there washed houses price
house price levels the rental yields
like so it's yeah it's just generally
finding out from from them really
because they live unable to work there
so yeah really use then no and then what
do you call the agent do you go and
visit them yeah we call them and it's a
mixture of both really psi on the agent
answer best a we've Samuel speaking how
can I help
what do you say and at this point they
don't know at this point they don't know
whether you're 16 years old or 36 years
old they look but but but if if you're
ringing them and you're thinking oh my
gosh I'm 18 I'm 18 I'm 18 I'm 18 I'm 18
then they're gonna be thinking oh he
sounds like he's only 18 but if you
don't know
I've got 190 million dollar company one
into that that's great okay so you ring
up you straight to the point you tell
them what you're looking for you booked
some viewings and then how do you work
out whether a deal is good or bad
it's all on the figures really
calculating between the purchase price
on the rental income coming in so just
do some basic maths on them you want to
go through how we
for example like the target rental yield
was above 9% little in track so fairly
easy to be honest is that return on
investment was like yield yield
okay which is pretty decent when you get
approached to the contacts regular can
we do this like you started to
self-doubt but then you have to realize
now yeah we've learned how to do it we
will do it yeah just like the mouse
price insight and looking at other
properties to let in the area and just
putting those two together so get an
idea of the rent and then you would call
the agency you know as a tenant what you
would pay for rent in that area yeah so
it's not just don't go buy one agent
call multiple in the area yeah I love
that as well as in ring up as a tenant
to get the real inside information
guys you so basically what you've done
is you've just come to the crash course
and you've actually just applied and
implemented everything and you've got
okay so so so far then first thing is
confidence to go and speak to the agents
to going to speak to people to get the
deals then its assess the deals but in
the due diligence while working out the
yield the return on investment all that
side of things let's say okay brilliant
you got some brilliant deals how did you
how did you how did you then land this
client how did how did how did they
foreign G or how did you find them so
it's really when we first tied up a
company got compliant within a few weeks
and then yeah we just marked yourself so
as you said tell the whole world that we
have property investors so we're quiet
yeah we ask why be able following from
previous Eunice's so we luckily had this
platform where we could mark it on and
then yeah this company just reach out so
saying we we have this project we have
this many properties can you just stop
you right there because you said we
luckily have this platform
no luckily you built this you created
this because because because at all I
don't have that platform well you've got
to go and create the platform you you
not aggressively that's the wrong word
but proactively
we're saying to me dude I've got a story
here I need to come on winners Wednesday
right yeah
story here where teenagers we're killing
it we just landed this big this big deal
I've got a story that's what you got to
do to grow your brand you know be
proactive so so you built that okay cool
and then and then tell the world that
your property investor saw what you
start saying guys wins property now this
is what we're doing
changing your LinkedIn stuff and then
someone reaches out to you yeah this
just conscious conscious play that and
then they wanted to sample properties to
see if we can meet up to the standard we
sourced them fairly quickly within a few
hours yeah we sent that cross to them
and they were blown away because they
contacted other sources and there were
nothing compared to what we found yeah
because you know how to find good deals
again the market doesn't discriminate if
you're finding if you're producing the
goods doing the due diligence probably
doing the research you've set yourself
up become compliant the real deal and
you don't have to fake you know you
don't have to sort of pretend you've
been in the game for ten years you can
be look you know what we're quite new to
this but here's the deal which speaks
for itself
exactly so they're paying you one
percent of the deals that you found and
that's up to 100 million which is insane
how many properties have you found them
so we've just completed on for today we
just had we just had the phone call
today they're saying it's all been
approved and processed on the dotted
line and on the deadline thank you for
how much have you made then just today
and which have you made so today what
1800 it's incredible just three days
worth of work that's incredible and you
know what's really interesting is that
most people like to make that kind of
money in just the last few days 1800
most people think that you need a lot of
investors you don't necessarily need a
lot of investors you just need one two
three four that I've prepared to do
business with you again and again and
again
that's it have recurring clients yeah
once you have that recurrent client and
they're happy with what you do they're
gonna continue always yeah well it's
almost like as you say 1.9 million if
they invested the whole lot and they did
it we through you if they're happy with
the deals you'll produce in which they
it looks what they are like
just-just-just source them to deals a
month and that's like an income it's
almost like financial freedom from one
client as a deal source that as a
teenager which that's what we should
maybe title this video but that's it
that's amazing so what's the biggest
things than that you've learned over the
process of doing this ask a lot of
questions yeah what do you mean find out
use the East Asians to your advantage
they know everything by the proper teens
are now so make sure you ask the right
questions just like the different types
of tennis was lease holes you know is a
freehold is resold stuff like that and
find out the history of the property why
is the vendor selling it you can
potentially get a lease option agreement
out of it if you found out yeah doing
the investigation right you're like
detectives literally oh you are you're a
little detective seeing means another
property also go view the property
that's another important thing I would
say have a good look around the property
make sure it's it's it's exactly what
the agent is telling away is because
sometimes I do like to bend the truth of
it to sell the property to you yeah so
definitely carry out a lot of research
and don't just find one or right
movement yeah we found your property
yeah yeah exactly it's got to be a good
deal otherwise they're not going to come
back from all right what about yourself
down yeah what do you explain what you
mean by back then so you would qualify
[Music]
then they were sailors like you know
they could say like oh I paid 350 a
month something they could say if you
were looking at by now oh yeah a few
minute about this how you can get 500
right right yeah so your your youngest
what role playing to get the truth but
then also another great thing about
doing that is you get to it's almost
like mystery shopping because some
agents might if there's a letting angels
watching this might think ah ringing me
up pretending to be someone you're not
wasting our time no no no it's not waste
that time it's checking that you are a
good agent
mister who's shopping you and then if
you if you come across well on the phone
then you're gonna then use them as part
your power same and then you've got not
190 million pounds to buy houses and let
them manage just because it's like a
mystery shop so I don't think there's
anything wrong with that at all I mean I
even mystery shop my own office
sometimes you know I'll ring up and just
check people answering the phone
professionally and quickly so so so
that's that's a that's a great tip
what's what's the future looking like
for you guys then what's the plans so we
we definitely want to move in to buy
refurbish refinance yeah so that's a big
thing for us and if a great thing is
well like you know I know you've not
you've not paid me a penny yeah
nothing if you've watched my youtube
videos you've been on the crash course
and as a result you're doing these kind
of deals so you know I just think that's
a real testament as well to how great
the free stuff is sometimes there's free
resources out there there's books
there's podcasts there's which which is
fantastic you know so I'm really
impressed I'm hoping that you'll do some
advanced training as well that's
important yeah definitely I think that
we will need it for when we move into
bigger projects and something definitely
want to move into the commercial side of
things as well amazing but you've
implemented what you've learned made a
massive success of it what will be your
biggest advice to people watching this
and they're thinking they want to get
started they want to start making money
whether let me through deal source in
what would your advice be what should
they do what are the next steps how do
they get started then the first thing is
to get educated so
definitely signed for the crash course
one of the biggest benefits you get 14
hours yeah so even after you take action
yeah don't hold back just do it don't be
scared
yeah and obviously it doesn't take that
much capital startups awesomeness does
it just the compliant yeah what like a
grand or two yeah people cuz people ask
me and I'm thinking it was a long time
ago and I got set up so I don't even
remember what the cost is to set up a
business and I know there are there are
some costs but I think we spend about
1400 yeah and that's the thing I mean if
you're so worried about spending a few
hundred pound here and there you know
people so I can't come to the crash
course because of the I can't afford the
hotels I can't afford to be a deal
sorcerer because I can't afford to get
insurance to become compliant it's like
if you're that small minded they that
you're worrying about the few hundred or
the few thousand pounds to change your
life into the end of a it is a business
you know so I think some people almost
they just expect to be able to make
money with no money no work no but it is
work it takes work it's effort it's a
business but regardless of your starting
point if you're starting out with no
money and you're starting out with no
experience and nothing you can do it
because anyone can get their hands on a
few thousand what do you think you agree
with that I agree with that we've proven
this because we literally done it again
a proven example so for people to use
that excuse they have no money it's just
how do you get your hands on the first
few thousand pounds just to kind of get
started to get it whether it would be
the education whether it be the the
compliance that the travel and the
transport that first little bit of
startup money how do you get that
we literally approached a friend thing
and
borrow us this money and yeah he
believed in the business and us and yeah
so did he give you a free loan did you
give him interest it was a gift
it was literally a free lawn so if I pay
back whenever you get your first deal
and we're literally gonna be paying him
back the next week so right so it's
totally nobody town for you guys so
why'd you reckon he trusted you to do
that did he want to be part of your
story did he want to support you what
was what was in it for him you just want
to support us become financially free
because he's recently became financially
free he wanted us to do the same so yeah
he's like you went through the crash we
brought him to the crash course yeah
Rome along to the crash and you know
what though in this industry I feel that
people want to help people in the
property business or I want to help
people but they want to help each other
yeah like our dropsy Facebook group like
a lot of people just helping each other
out that's cool so no money down
teenagers landing big deals inspiring
the rest of us it's great to have you
guys on I really appreciate you coming
out and I look forward to seeing what
you do next helping you get there and
awesome man guys if you're not inspired
after that I don't know what's wrong
with you if you want to be on winners
Wednesday yourself then why not come on
down to the property investors crash
course I'm gonna drop a link below so
you can get yourself booked on and look
forward to seeing you at the top
thanks so much drop a like drop a
comment subscribe I'll see you next time
[Music]